musk could be on his way out after
exposing the censorship scandal at
Twitter could he be the billionaire user
billionaire polled users on whether he
should step down as CEO of the social
media Giant and promising he would abide
by the results well the verdict is in
and 57 support his stepping down that
comes as we get a new batch of Twitter
files exposing the Cozy relationship
between the FBI and the social media
giant it shows the Bureau of bullying
Executives for not reporting State
propaganda enough it even caused
Twitter's former head of trust and
safety UL Roth to be uncomfortable he
was the guy who also banned people and
today we learned the FBI warned Twitter
about hacked information just hours
before the New York Post published its
Hunter Biden laptop story so Dana let's
start there because right before the
laptop story was published the FBI had
had the laptop for their possession for
a year I know and then I read today that
within these files they found that there
was an note from the ousted former FBI
and now former Twitter Deputy Council
James Baker thanking the FBI for helping
them get the hunter Biden laptop story
put away and so that looks very
suspicious and you have to imagine that
for Joel Roth who's the guy at Twitter
he was even irritated by the FBI and
saying Gosh guys like can you back off
we're still a private company and the
FBI had so many agents looking at them I
think it's pretty hilarious that they
fell for satirical sites and accounts
that had 12 followers how many times
have we made fun of people for
retweeting people that had 12 followers
like if you have a million followers and
you retweet someone's mean comment to
you and they had 12 followers then what
have you done right that doesn't make
any sense so there's a there is a lot
there I do think that Elon Musk has I'd
often says open Pandora's box but he
opened a box he's like wow this thing is
kind of terrible but it's also something
that should be fixed I want to try to
fix it but I also got to try to land a
guy on the moon next week so you need
somebody else to actually run the
day-to-day so Greg do you think Elon
Musk should stay or go oh he's got to go
because he already knew the outcome like
people people go why would he do this
because he he was he's playing planning
on going and he used this opportunity to
I guess teach us something about maybe
how you how Twitter could be used in the
future in terms of you know maybe
Twitter makes decisions baby it is a
high brain a human brain in which people
vote on things and maybe it's the future
of voting I mean it's like the idea like
if he wasn't stepping down he never
would have done this so he's gonna he's
definitely stepping down this was just a
great way to turn it into something else
I think that you know whoever he picks
for this he doesn't need a fire brand or
a Visionary because that's his job he's
still going to be running the thing no
matter what what he needs it's like if
this were like a TV show right he
basically needs a host a host who just
kind of shows up and like you know he's
the he needs the front of the store and
you need somebody that isn't that isn't
like I I was thinking like Charles
Barkley because I can't figure out where
he stands on anything like one minute
he'll say something so right wing and
then the next thing he says something so
left-wing and I go he's America like
it's this kind of like you can't have
anybody that's a that's like a regular
heater or a regular CNN it's got to be
somebody but then again or is it
somebody you don't know yes like
somebody you don't know who doesn't have
a purse persona persona we hear a lot
from the left especially on Capitol Hill
continuing on about misinformation
disinformation importance of Defending
democracy and yet we're seeing even more
what we suspected and proof of it that
the FBI had a heavy hand in the lead up
to the 2020 election in suppressing
information that could have changed as
part of the election
well I don't know if it would have
changed uh any anything in the election
what I do agree with wholeheartedly is
that I I'm against censorship regardless
of whom is instigating it or whom the it
might
help in the process and some may say
this could have helped Democrats
um I'm most concerned if these reports
are accurate and I have no reason to
believe that that many are not but we
need more information here why was the
FBI in at Twitter asking him to do
things normally when fbis what a private
company trying to gain information it's
either an active investigation underway
or there's something happening that they
need that information for to prevent
harm to the country that's the burden
that will be on the FBI to share with
the country I'm going to withhold
judgment but I have to tell you the
things that we're seeing from what Mr
musket and Mr Tybee and Miss uh Miss
weisser are releasing and shallow Burger
yeah and Sheldon Burger yeah exactly
um all of this is troubling and I think
it deserves an answer and a big set of
answers well one person trying to get
answers but do hope does what he said he
was going to do if he if he I'd agree
with Greg he probably knew the outcome
of that but if he said to people I'm
going to abide by the results he's got
to have a pretty compelling reason not
to buy about it I mean he's been
consistent into on when those polls come
out he does what the polls say Jesse
someone who wants to try and do
something about this issue with the FBI
or influencing Twitter is incoming he
thinks speaker Kevin McCarthy was this
nobody said what he's going to do and
get your take
we're going to do more than just
subpoena them we're going to change the
course of where the FBI is today if you
look the FBI is every day we learn
something more that they became and
could private companies become a
political arm of them to go after
individuals with no repercussions for
individuals that know what's happening
but it raises more questions
Jesse you're never going to beat the FBI
they're just too powerful
and I'm gonna get my hopes up and then
my heart's gonna get broken so I'm not
even going to how many times is that I
mean day after day after day
so
you go into the Twitter headquarters in
your FBI badge basically works there it
just lets you in and then they flash it
and Twitter says yes sir I'll do
whatever you want sir it's crazy there's
more FBI agents at Twitter than there
are Stanford graduates so the whole
company is now owned by the FBI that's
but we'll weed them out but it's going
to take a while
musk can't pull Twitter
that's a rigged poll excuse
atheist female Urban atheist
over-educated female we've seen the
metrics on it it's mostly single women
that have graduate degrees that's true
you can't pay attention that's like me
running for governor of Vermont it's
like I'm never gonna win that but be so
sure I'm a republican Governor now
really yeah me so but you need I have a
friend who's a turnaround artist they
hire him to go in not for 10 years they
hire him to go in for two years and turn
the place around to just fire a bunch of
people and then juice profits and then
get the hell out of there basically just
turn a place around and then send it in
the right direction that's what musk is
he's a turnaround artist you get in
there you find out all the crimes that
have been committed you make it
profitable and then you skid adult
because he has to stop tweeting based
stuff he's worth billions of dollars
he's got investors Republicans have a
lot of money in Tesla and all his
companies they don't want to hear the
CEO spouting off about God knows what on
social media they let quiet rich guys
that stay on the sidelines and hire
flame throwers you know who's a good
turnaround artist Brian Kilmeade
whenever I see him oh wow I turn around
what is the Urban atheist female
[Laughter]
everywhere they're very scary single
white women single white there are four
left and pro-abortion that's who's on
Twitter
okay hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else